let's go to Oskar next who is on the
line in Arizona Oscar how can I help
hello sir thank you for taking my call
appreciate it sure what's going on I am
a behavior health therapist I work with
youth who are hooked on drugs and I am
currently burnt out I am trying to find
my way out of this career but I invested
so much time in it and energy and it's
my passion but at the same time as I
feel like it's okay leading all right
Oscar Oscar I got great news for you I
know you feel burned out I don't
question for a second that you have the
feelings of being burned out but I got
great news you're not actually burned
out you're dealing with build up on the
heart now Oscar I'm going to identify
the five causes of build up and let's
see if you're experiencing all five or a
few of the five number one is no
connection to the work that's not your
deal you just told our entire audience
you're passionate about this work so
it's not a lack of connection and heart
with the actual job and role the second
cause is you're overwhelmed you feel
like the moment you pull in the parking
lot that you're absolutely about to
drown the third cause is is that you are
underappreciated you just you just don't
feel like anybody appreciates you okay
the other thing is is that you are
unrecognized and there's no reward in
the work you can't see it you're working
really hard you don't feel like that's
happening and then the fifth cause of
burnout excuse me buildup is that you're
just bored so which one do you think it
is because I think you got a couple
going on yes I do I have a couple okay
so tell me what's causing you to feel
that way tell let's identify it
specifically I do feel very overwhelmed
I have also been in my journey through
the baby steps and I developed other
ways of income so there are times in
which I question if I choose should I
just focus on those other areas and
necessary job not necessarily again what
I removed your workload okay you know
you're overwhelmed if we were to remove
what is causing you to feel and be
overwhelmed would you even be calling me
right now would you be feeling like hey
I mean if I'm doing what I'm doing and
I'm not overwhelmed and I don't feel
like I'm just about to overheat every
second of the day
do I still love the work yes or no yeah
the answer will be yeah yeah so here's
the deal
keep doing the stuff on the side that
makes more money that's all positive for
you but I deal with this call all the
time on the Ken Coleman show we got to
figure out what's causing us to feel the
symptoms of burnout and realize it's
build-up on the heart and when we can
remove the build-up the heart still hair
beating passionately I can feel my heart
right here right now in the studio if I
put a bunch of blankets or thick coats
on I know my heart is there but it is so
covered up by all the layers I can't
feel it burn out doesn't exist if you're
alive you're not burned out you're just
dealing with build-up let's remove the
cause of build-up and the heart is
beating as strong as it ever has been